ma question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre l'intérieur monsieur ministre
mars dernier le rappeur nick conrad
était condamné pour provocation au crime
pour son clip intitulé pendez les blancs
manifestement ni la honte d'une
condamnation pénale ni la peine
prononcée ne leur ont amené à réfléchir
en effet le rappeur hommelibre comme il
aime à se présenter lui-même viennent de
réitérer son propos dans son nouveau
clip aux paroles sans ambiguïté je cite
je baise la france je brûle la france
jusqu'à l'agonie
tel est le refrain lancinant de ce qu'il
présente comme une oeuvre de l'esprit
en dehors des propos tenus les images
laisse également peu de place à
l'interprétation
dans ce clip à large diffusion on y voit
l'auteur après sa divulgation en berline
clamer sa haine de la france et procéder
avec méthode à la strangulation d'une
jeune femme à terre tout cela suivi
dents oral dans ralenti complaisant
filmant son rictus de satisfaction
devant son crime
amené à s'expliquer sur ses propos et
ses images où l'auteur évoque tour à
tour la faute des médias et de la
mentalité française qui selon lui
refuserait je cite d'ouvrir le sujet
épineux de lentilles esclavagisme de la
france or monsieur ministre ne saurait
en pareil cas s'abriter derrière la
liberté de création ou la liberté
d'expression pour tout justifier les
limites aux me semble-t-il largement été
outrepassées vous avez indiqué monsieur
ministre procédé un signalement sur la
patente pharos et saisir le procureur de
la république
c'est bien nous y souscrivons mais on ne
peut pas se contenter de se défausser
sur la justice nous attendons une
réponse politique ferme et une
affirmation claire de nos principes dès
lors monsieur le ministre comment
comptez-vous au delà de la condamnation
de principe obligé faire en sorte que ce
type de propos n'est plus droit de cité
d'entre eux pays la parole est au
secrétaire d'état auprès de l'intérieur
monsieur le roannais
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur bonhomme vous rappeler le
contenu donc de ce vidéo clip de ce
rappeur on dit que conrad qui une
nouvelle fois tient des propos
particulièrement injurieux haineux mais
qui s'en prennent directement à la
france jeudi une nouvelle fois parce que
vous avez raison de le rappeler dans un
précédent clip il avait appelé à pendre
des blancs et donc je voulais vous dire
d'abord que le gouvernement partage bien
évidemment votre émotion et votre
indignation devant ces propos injurieux
qui sont inacceptables et qui
effectivement ne doivent pas être
acceptées ni conrad doit comprendre que
de tels propos ne peuvent pas s'abriter
et vous l'avez rappelé monsieur le
sénateur derrière la liberté
d'expression ou derrière une quelconque
liberté artistique l'insultent et la
haine ne sont pas de l'arc insultes et
la haine ne vont pas dans le sens du
vivre ensemble auquel nous appelons tous
dans notre démocratie française mais
surtout l'insulté la haine tombent sous
le coup de la loi pénale
et c'est en ce sens que christophe
castaner dès dimanche à dans le cadre
d'un article 40 du code de procédure
pénale saisi le procureur de la
république de paris qui a immédiatement
ouvert une enquête préliminaire dont il
a saisi la brigade de répression de la
délinquance contre les personnes de la
police judiciaire de la préfecture de
police de paris qui a ouvert au titre de
l'apologie de crime d'atteinte
volontaire aggravé qui est une
infraction extrêmement grave et les
enquêteurs donc sont à l'oeuvre et des
auditions ont lieu très prochainement
mais là je ne peux en dire plus bien
évidemment ça se passe sous l'autorité
du parquet
dans le même temps christophe castaner a
souhaité que nous puissions saisir la
plateforme pharos qui travaillent à
obtenir le retrait de ce contenu qui est
manifestement illicite
dans le même temps donc pharos travail à
cette possibilité de retrait mais ce que
je veux dire aussi c'est que cette cette
affaire doit aussi nous faire persévérer
poursuivre dans la voie qu'ils aient les
nôtres la nôtre d'adopter un texte de
loi c'est la proposition de loi qui sera
bientôt présenté à l'assemblée et ce
projet qu'il faut aussi que nous
portions au parlement européen auprès
des institutions européennes pour
obtenir comme c'est le cas pour le
compte les contenus terroristes le
retrait dans les plus brefs délais des
contenus
haineux comme c'est le cas
malheureusement avec une nouvelle fois
ce clip de nick conrad merci monsieur
bonhomme monsieur ministre j'observe
toutefois quand même que la diffusion du
clip malgré les signalements sur pharos
demeure et d'autre part j'aurais voulu
une condamnation en général parce que
j'ai observé le silence gêné et
assourdissantes de madame schiappa qui
est en charge de l'égalité hommes-femmes
et des discriminations
pourtant toujours prompte à fanfaronner
et apte à théâtraliser ses sorties
toujours prompte à manier twitter et
notamment le hashtag notamment le
hashtag ne rien laisser passer et serait
donnée surtout beaucoup plus de force à
notre peau